The hierarchy of power in the DC universe
is… disputed, at this point.
"The hierarchy of power in the DC universe
is about to change."
If your perception of "Black Adam" is based
on the ad campaign and Dwayne Johnson's hype
machine, you'd think it was the greatest thing
since sliced bread.
But reality appears to be a little bit more
complicated.
While it's far from a trainwreck of a film,
"Black Adam" is also far from the paradigm-shifting
film it was made out to be.
Even with the inclusion of the Justice Society
of America, Henry Cavill's Superman, and Johnson
finally portraying DC Comics' Teth-Adam after
years of waiting, people didn't exactly rush
to the theater to check the movie out.
While it claimed the top spot at the weekend
box office a few times in its run, "Black
Adam's" performance has been relatively muted
– especially compared to the much bigger
run of "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
"Black Adam" is resting just under the $400
million mark in terms of worldwide box office gross.
In isolation, that's an impressive number.
For a superhero movie starring one of the
world's biggest movie stars, it's a little
bit sus.
Taken in context with the movie's reported
$200 million budget, as well as a reported
$100 million marketing campaign, the amount
of money "Black Adam" has brought in starts
seeming pretty small.
But is it actually going to lose money?
That's a point being hotly contested by industry
reporters, the studio, and the movie's star
producer, Dwayne Johnson himself.
That debate has a new wrinkle now with a bombshell
report that Johnson's camp leaked misleading
financial info about "Black Adam" on purpose,
to help spin the movie's performance as positive
– and profitable.
Here's what the rumor mill has churned up
about this situation so far.
"These powers are not a gift, but a curse."
On December 7, 2022, Deadline explained that
contrary to other reports citing "Black Adam"
as a financial failure, the movie stands to
rake in some profit after all.
The rough window Deadline reported puts the
film's projected earnings between $52 and
$72 million – a number which allegedly includes
merchandise related to the film.
Less than a week later, however, former editor
of The Hollywood Reporter Matt Belloni came
forward with a surprising claim that appeared
to contradict those numbers.
Not only will "Black Adam" not bring in millions
for Warner Bros. Discovery, but according
to Belloni's sources, Dwayne Johnson 's team
purposely leaked false financial information
to the press.
On the industry newsletter Puck, Belloni wrote,
Belloni clarified that no one on Johnson's
team has yet admitted to any such leak.
Instead, he claims that individuals within
Warner Bros. Discovery have expressed their
belief that Johnson put those misleading numbers
out there, leading to outlets like Deadline
reporting on it and propagating a positive
spin for the movie.
If this report from Matt Belloni is true,
it raises questions about the ramifications
for the movie's future in the DC universe,
as well as Dwayne Johnson's relationship with
Warner Bros. Discovery.
Before this rumor came to light, we learned
that major shake-ups are on the way for DC,
and the "Black Adam" brand might have a lot
to worry about.
On December 7, 2022, The Hollywood Reporter
noted that under the guidance of James Gunn
and Peter Safran, the DC film and television
slate is supposedly up for some big changes.
"Wonder Woman 3" has been canned, Jason Momoa
could switch from Aquaman to Lobo, and Henry
Cavill may already be done as Superman even
though he just returned to the role.
THR also reported that the first Black Adam's
financial woes could take a sequel off the
table entirely, regardless of what Johnson
– or the movie's tantalizing post-credits
scene – might have you believe.
So is the movie a total failure?
That's up in the air – but if it was successful,
we probably wouldn't have to ask.
For now, the big question is whether or not
"Black Adam" is really going to turn a profit,
or if it's doomed to stay in the red.
"I kneel before no one."